vu mike tyson mike tyson dans la cabine
comment en string mike tyson les
fonctions possibles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en mai
c'est bon pour nous
[Musique]
rien
moko est très simple il y a quelque
chose derrière
derrière ce rideau où il regardé très
discrètement tous les deux et on va
devoir dire ce qu'on voit tu peut
bluffer winehouse
tu peux dire la vérité ah oui d'accord
il faut qu'il faut que tu n es qu il va
regarder il va nous dire ce qu'ils
voient elles acceptent de jouer le jeu
derrière il ya evangeline habillés
maquillés en stage à geneviève de
fontenay en train de jouer du biniou qui
dit la vérité mérite chez moi
[Rires]
alors je vous le monde le croit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors d'accord je vais regarder monsieur
ya une poule de luxe
oh c'est pas moi c'est pas bonne les
poules une poule de luxe
il y a quelqu'un vous connaissez
roselyne bachelot habillée en cerise de
groupama et ne rendent pas et qu ils
font gilles verdez louis cohen l'air
convaincu qu elle s'appelle antoine
couilles
merci roselyne c'est cool non je prends
c'est la poule est une boule de feu
si tu peux plus la pole salle pour
regarder
[Applaudissements]
regardez et elle a des besoins de l inde
et après qu'est la dpj c'est le poulet
nourri chat à jouer avec toi tu joues
avec oh tu va nous dire ce que tu vois
laurie alors il va zy je les regarde
avec toi regardez j'ai vu mike tyson
mike tyson dans la cabine comment en
string mike tyson opté fonctionne soit
possible quand même ouais j'ai vu celle
qu'on avait envie de claquer quand on
était gamins à la télé nellie oleson de
la petite maison dans la prairie
mais en modèle qu'elle tombe pas dans la
colline à l'est d'où elle est en jeu
avec la truck de l'époque au regard des
kia il ya des lieux
auto
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]